President Trump is inviting new Supreme
Court justice Brett Kavanaugh to the
White House today for swearing-in
ceremony Cavanaugh took his oath on
Saturday after one of the closest ever
votes for Supreme Court nominee
Democrats argue the fight over this
nominee really started before the 2016
election when Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell blocked President
Obama's nomination of Judge Merrick
garland to the High Court on Face the
Nation yesterday McConnell insisted that
history was on his side you have to go
back to 1880 to find the last time a
Senate controlled by a different party
from the president confirmed a Supreme
Court justice to a vacancy created in
the middle of a presidential election
mr. leader I don't think that's right in
1956 Eisenhower nominated Brennan that
the 84th Congress was a Democrat
controlled you're completely
misconstruing what happened what I gave
you is the history of this I know the
history of this when a Democratic
president puts somebody forward the
Republican leader worked with him to get
that person a hearing and get him
towards the Supreme Court which is not
something that you did a vote at the
time and there was a Democrat then it
was a Democrat in the White House and a
Democratic Senate but the Republican
leader tried to help try to make John
John you are not listening to me the
history is is exactly as I told you well
there are two different moments there we
were debating but let's focus just on
Justice William Brennan in 1956 he was a
recess appointment by a Republican
president he was then confirmed by
Democrats in 1957 after Eisenhower was
reelected but the point was it is was
not Senate precedent to refuse to
confirm or even give a hearing to
justices so voters could have their say
in an election year which was the
original rationale used for not giving
America garland a hearing does he not
know that you are walking talking
political encyclopedia that you were
best-selling author of Whistlestop all
about politics with our history well it
was the the 1956 example is tricky and
complicated which we were trying to work
out and then we started talking about
1968 which is a slightly different issue
the question is whether the history is
being whether he's changing this the the
rationale he used for blocking Garland
at which he which he's doing in part so
that if a Supreme Court seat comes up in
2020 the Year Donald Trump is up for
re-election they can use history to
allow a Supreme Court nominee to be
named let the record show it was a civil
conversation absolutely
good disagreement on both side we only
had more time we could have worked at
all a party early I know you could have